putting on the very latest with this for
us John Parris good afternoon to you
this morning DHS is cyber security and
infrastructure security agency together
with the FBI pointed a very big finger
at China in terms of tried to hack our
research organizations who are looking
into coronavirus in a public service
announcement they were warning us
organizations who are researching
coronavirus that they are likely being
targeted by Chinese government cyber
hackers the agencies charging that China
is trying to steal research information
on the virus treatments and vaccines in
its public advisory the agency's warning
researchers to secure their network
saying quote these actors have been
observed attempting to identify and
illicitly obtain valuable intellectual
property and public health data related
to vaccines treatments and testing the
potential theft of this information
jeopardizes the delivery of secure
effective and efficient treatment
options president Trump has been very
critical of China for not being
forthcoming about the origins of the
pandemic South Carolina Senator Lindsey
Graham has introduced a bill to impose
sanctions on China if it fails to
cooperate and provide a full accounting
of the events leading up to the pandemic
Georgia congressman Doug Collins on that
earlier this morning on Fox listened
here China deceived the world while
people were dying they were taking
precautions inside their own borders
while yet letting people go
internationally it is time for an
independent investigation led by the US
and others to make sure that they number
one going forward what actually happened
and we hold them accountable the Chinese
officials who did this they need to be
in a position where they can be
sanctioned where they can be their
assets frozen those are the kind of
things that we look at is usually the
economic impact of the pandemic to try
to get a better trade deal with the
United States than the one that had
agreed to last year the president saying
he is not interested in reopening
negotiations at least not at this point
and the president tightening the screws
even further directing the federal
retirement thrift board to not invest in
any stock funds that have ties to
Chinese companies that means that about
four and a half billion dollars that
might have gone into stock funds that
have interests in China will stay in
other investments like
the United States but the president
clearly indicating again Harrison's 70
different ways just how unhappy he is
with China about all of this though he
has and still remains to be very very
cautious about actually criticizing
China's President Xi Jinping Harris